what is up ahs universe i just finished
my episode 3 breakdown video and you
know what i got a little bit more energy
in me to do a quick video on the double
feature episode 4 preview if you haven't
given it a look i've left a link to it
in the description but we're not going
to waste any time so hit that like and
subscribe button because i have some
cool theories based on the latest
trailer like if we'll be getting a pale
person origin story i can already tell
i'm gonna like this episode when it's
titled blood buffet with the description
that reads the dark history of
provincetown and its residents are
brought to light and we do get
confirmation in this preview that there
will be flashbacks the only question is
how far back they will go with
provincetown's history spanning all the
way back to the pilgrims in 1620 the
year is even on chief burleson's police
uniform i wonder if we'll go as far back
as the events of roanoke we've seen
these images in previous trailers before
of the chemist in a lab creating the
black pill as far as we know she is
working on her own but with a lot of
government presence in part 2 death
valley it's possible there may be a
connection i've also heard some people
say that chemist could be a witch but i
really haven't found any solid clues
that back that theory up just yet and if
she were a witch why would she need this
lab we do get this mermaid door knocker
so if anything she may be some sort of
siren being able to control anyone who
takes the black pill just like a siren
could control those under her spell
here's the chemist in her home giving a
black pill to belle noire for the first
time or should we say her real name
sarah cunningham i believe she becomes
belle noire after she becomes this
famous writer no word yet if she has any
familial link to elias cunningham from
season six roanoke belle tells the
chemist she's willing to do whatever it
takes even though the chemist says it
comes with side effects like cravings
mickey is also here but as far as we
know the first time he ever took a pill
was in episode 2. so my guess is that
mickey was either hired by the chemist
to bring her test subjects or he was
brought here and turned down the pill i
also want you to take note of what belle
is wearing here the same shirt she wears
when she smashes a wine bottle and
supposedly strikes this man perhaps her
husband we do see her wearing a wedding
ring here we also see that she's in a
hotel room having finished a bottle of
wine and these tissues hint that she was
also having a cry if this is her husband
or someone close to her it may not be
someone very nice as belle attacks them
with the broken wine bottle okay this is
the guy who i really wanted to talk
about i'm about 99 sure this is the main
pale guy we've seen in episode one the
guy who plays him on imdb looks a lot
like him too whoever he is seems to know
the chemist personally over the course
of the trailer we see him look exhausted
and pull out his hair we know the pale
people are bald and those that take the
black pill who don't have any talent
turn into them so it's easy to assume he
takes one of the pills from the chemist
and begins his transformation into a
pale person mickey is also at this gay
bar or at least i think it is with this
rainbow flag here and other symbol here
and we can also see belle noir dancing
in the background but we aren't sure if
this is before or after she takes the
pill or if this is where mickey first
meets her we've seen this image in some
of the previous trailers of a woman
bending down in front of the pale man
but the curious thing here is the
bouquet of flowers he's holding could
this be someone finally figuring out the
pale man's true identity perhaps someone
who once was very close to him or vice
versa over here we have belle noire
scoping out a drag show she's likely
looking for someone with talent to bring
into the black pill fold this person
looks like it's going to be austin
summers before he was a tony-winning
writer he's dressed in drag and if i
were to hazard a guess he might be
singing something from rocky horror as
he's wearing a similar getup and pearls
like frankenferder a lot of people here
are also dressed up we have a sailor
another drag queen and a guy with makeup
resembling evan peters tate langdon the
day he shot up his school there are also
pumpkins and bats suggesting it's around
halloween now here's an interesting
image mickey and tb karen looking pretty
healthy at the bar at least
comparatively to how we've seen them
even karen's teeth look markedly better
this might be before the two of them
succumb to drug addiction interesting to
note here tb karen still wears her
gloves and check out this piece of paper
did mickey get a number bell offers
austin a pill saying let's go get you
fed it's not exactly clear what belle's
motives are here perhaps she just got
lonely and wanted a talented friend to
be with her but i'm sure more will be
revealed next episode thanks everyone
for watching if you haven't checked out
my episode 3 breakdown be sure to do
that as well as like the video for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at think story yt until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much